how to advertise your app apps are
everywhere
right and it's great it could be a great
business to get into because it's so
scalable right you put a lot of work in
at the beginning but then adding new
customers doesn't cost you anything the
problem is there's so many apps on the
market and most of them are crap it's so
easy to get in that it's hard to stand
out against everybody else so how do you
do it this comes from a question from
one of my YouTube viewers Herman willing
to say I have a question for you I'm an
app developer I develop apps for iPhone
my question is I'm looking for ways to
advertise my app everything inside the
app is ready the only thing that's left
is sending the app into the App Store do
you have any tips for advertising it
here's how I would do it okay the first
thing is make sure that the app is great
because nothing's going to help you if
you have a crappy product you want
something that people will talk about ok
I don't know what your model is I tend
to lean towards the freemium apps
it starts off free and then there's so
much value in them that you end up
paying for it I paid for a number of
apps that have gone through that model
and it's a great way to build a business
you want people talking about your app
ok I don't know how many times I've gone
up to people friends family and I've had
my phone and I've talked about the apps
that I use people ask me and I've done
videos what are the apps that you use
and you can you get a sense of a
person's life just by looking at the
homepage of their phone by seeing what
apps that they use ok people like to
talk about this stuff if I discover a
new app I'm making a video on it I'm
telling my friends about it so that the
first step for you is making sure that
your app is amazing so hopefully that's
built in something I want to talk about
because it's so great the next thing is
you have to start even with your own
network of telling people about your app
and what it does and what problem it
solves why do people need to care about
this thing right you wrote into me I'm
making a video for you this is going on
my channel you know coming up on a
million views on my channel I don't even
know what your app does right I could be
play
you right now Herman's got this app it
does this for them the iPhone right you
got to tell people what do you do
what is the app do and what major
problem does it solve in everything that
you put out okay if you're talking to
people your friends business you have to
let people know and it's not a sales
pitch it's not here's why you need to go
buy my app or download my app people are
genuinely curious in what other people
are up to right if I see a friend that I
haven't seen for a while what do I ask
hey what's been going on what are you up
to I just developed this app here's what
it does right it doesn't have to be a
sales pitch but you got to let people
know what it is that you're doing this
is the start okay this is how you start
building this even just through your
friends and family and in talking to
people like me who are talking about
your videos and your apps okay this is
how you get it started but it has to
start with what it is that you do the
third thing I would do is start reaching
out to people reach out to people who
have your target audience so if you're
targeting entrepreneurs if on Troopers
are going to use your app then I'm a
great person to talk to if you're
targeting scientists if you're targeting
librarians if you're targeting teenage
girls whatever it is there are people
who are influencers to your target
market reach out to them let them know
what you're doing I like things that
relate to entrepreneurs right I live and
breathe entrepreneurship most of the
stuff I do for entrepreneurship I don't
get paid to do I'm not getting paid to
make this video as far as I know Herman
you know if you want to buy me something
let's get to but you know I love this
stuff because I live and breathe
entrepreneurship if there was an app for
entrepreneurs and it was great I would
check it out you wouldn't have to do a
huge sales job on me because that's what
I love doing anyway if the app is great
I'm gonna check it out I'm going to tell
my friends I'm going to say hey you need
to check this out I'm going to make a
video
I'm going to tweet about it so that's my
three-step plan okay number one the app
has to be great don't release a crappy
product release something that people
will use or put on the homepage of their
phone and will want to tell their four
about if it's not keep tinkering and
make it great at least for a select
target audience pick a group of people
who you want to target who use who will
will live with your app it's got to be
that good
for somebody then start telling people
about it your friends family people who
you're talking to let them know here's
the app here's what I'm working on
here's the problem that it helps and
then start reaching out to people start
reaching out to the influencers who
control your audience who can if they
say this is a good thing they're going
to go do it believe we're watching if
you liked this video please give it a
thumbs up below you have a comment leave
it below you have a question leave it
below you have an app you want to
promote that helps entrepreneurs put in
the comments I might check it out might
do a video on it you never know thank
you everybody
I'll see you soon